pergunta: "Podemos conviver bem com
doença autoimune? E como controlar? Sabe
aquela sensação de acordar já bem
cansado mesmo depois de dormir a noite
toda? Ou quando você come algo e parece
que o seu corpo entra em guerra consigo
mesmo? Pois é, meu amigo, muita gente tá
passando por isso hoje em dia. E olha
só, pode ser que o seu sistema
imunológico esteja meio confuso, sabe? É
como se ele fosse aquele amigo super
protetor que acaba exagerando na dose e
brigando até com que não deveria.
Quando falamos de doenças autoimunes,
estamos falando exatamente disso.
Imagina só, seu sistema de defesa, que
deveria ser um tipo um guardião, um
guarda-costas particular, começa a
atacar o seu próprio organismo, a célula
do seu próprio corpo. É como se o
segurança da sua casa começasse a
quebrar seus próprios móveis, achando
que são invasores. Loucura, né? E o pior
que isso não é tão raro quanto parece.
Temos o lupus, artriteamatoide, a tiro
de rashimoto, a psoríase, a esclerose
múltipla. A lista é grande, viu? Mas
calma, não precisa entrar em pânico. A
boa notícia é que dá para conviver numa
boa com essas condições. E é aqui que a
medicina funcional entra como uma
verdadeira revolução. Sabe por quê?
Porque ao invés de só tapar o sol com a
peneira, tratando apenas os sintomas,
ela vai na raiz dos problemas. É tipo
quando você tem uma infiltração em casa
que não adianta só pintar a parede, tem
que achar de onde vem a água, entende? E
tem uma coisa muito importante que a
gente precisa falar, o intestino. Pois
é, nosso intestino é tipo centro de
comando do nosso corpo. Quando ele tá
bagunçado, com o que nós chamamos de
intestino permeável ou hiperpemeável ou
liquig ou mesmo disbiose, é como se a
porta de casa tivesse aberta e qualquer
um pudesse entrar. As toxinas e
bactérias ruins passam direto pra
corrente sanguínea e aí o sistema imune
fica doido, atacando tudo que vem pela
frente. Agora, deixa eu te contar sobre
uma estratégia poderosa, o protocolo AIP
ou o protocolo autoimune pálio. Pode
parecer nome de ficção científica, né?
Parece nome de filme, mas é bem simples.
É basicamente uma forma de comer que
ajuda o seu corpo a se acalmar, reduzir
inflamação e dar uma trégua pro sistema
de defesa imune. Estudos recentes
mostraram que cerca de 73% das pessoas
que seguem esse protocolo consegue uma
melhora significativa dos sintomas em
apenas seis semanas. Impressionante, não
é mesmo? E o protocolo funciona como?
Funciona assim. Primeiro você tira da
dieta tudo que pode estar causando
inflamação. E olha, não é pouca coisa
não. Os maiores culpados, glúten,
laticínios, ovos, grãos, leguminosas,
açúcar refinado, álcool, café. Eu sei,
eu sei. Parece que não sobra nada para
comer, mas calma, tem muita coisa boa
que pode. Carne de qualidade, peixes,
muitas verduras, legumes, frutas com
moderação, gorduras boas com abacate,
azeite de oliva. É uma fase de
eliminação que dura pelo menos 30 dias,
mas pode chegar a 90 dias, dependendo do
caso. E não é só sobre comida, viu? O
estresse é um baita vilão. Quando
falamos de doenças autoimunes, é como
jogar gasolina no fogo. Por isso, a
medicina funcional olha pra pessoa como
um todo. Dormir bem é fundamental. E não
tô falando de ficar rolando na cama,
olhando o celular até tarde. Eu tô
falando de um sono repador e de
qualidade. Exercício físico também entra
na jogada. Sem exageros. é encontrar
aquele ponto ideal onde você se
movimenta, mas sem estressar demais o
seu organismo. Depois da fase de
eliminação, vem a parte interessante, a
reintrodução. É como se fosse um
trabalho detetive. Você vai adicionando
um alimento por vez e observando como é
que o seu corpo reage. Deu coceira,
inchou, ficou cansado? Então esse
alimento ainda não é para você. É um
processo bem individualizado, porque
cada corpo é um corpo. Cada corpo é
único, ok? O que funciona pro seu
vizinho pode não funcionar para você. E
tem mais uma coisa bacana, os alimentos
fermentados, kefir, chucrute, cobuxá,
esses caras são tipos melhores amigos do
seu intestino. Eles trazem bactérias do
bem que ajudam a reequilibrar toda a
flora intestinal. É como chamar reforços
pro time do bem. E quando o intestino tá
feliz, o seu corpo agradece.
A suplementação também pode entrar como
uma aliada poderosa, mas sempre
personalizada. Não é sair tomando tudo
que o vizinho indica, não. Vitamina D,
ômega-3, probióticos específicos,
vitaminas do complexo B, cada pessoa vai
precisar de uma combinação diferente. É
por isso que o acompanhamento
profissional médico é tão importante
também nutricional. Olha, eu sei que
pode parecer muita mudança de uma vez,
mas pensa comigo, você prefere continuar
vivendo com uma qualidade de vida
horrível, dor, fadiga, inflamação, ou
prefere investir alguns meses da sua
vida para descobrir como seu corpo
funciona melhor? É como aprender a
dirigir. No começo parece impossível
coordenar tudo, mas depois vira
automático. E não estamos falando de uma
dieta temporária, ok? Estamos falando de
uma mudança de estilo de vida. é
reaprender a se relacionar com a comida,
com sono, com estresse, com atividade
física. É entender que seu corpo não é o
seu inimigo. Ele tá só pedindo ajuda,
pedindo socorro do jeito que ele sabe.
Quando você começa a escutar esses
sinais e agir de acordo, a mágica
acontece, a energia volta, a disposição
melhora, aquela nerva mental fogue, some
e as dores diminuem. Tem gente que
consegue até reduzir ou eliminar
medicamentos, mas, ó, sempre com
acompanhamento médico, viu? Não é para
sair fazendo besteira por aí. A ideia é
trabalhar em parceria, você, seu corpo e
os profissionais de saúde, todos
remandoam pro mesmo lado. Então, bora
lá. Que tal começar hoje mesmo a prestar
mais atenção no que você come, em como
você dorme, em como lida com estresse?
Pequenas mudanças podem trazer grandes
resultados. E lembra, você não tá
sozinho nessa parada. Tem muita gente
passando pelo mesmo processo e
descobrindo que é possível sim viver bem
com uma doença autoimune. É possível sim
ter qualidade de vida, energia,
disposição. É possível sim voltar a ser
você mesmo, sabe? Afinal, o seu corpo é
sua casa pra vida toda. Vale a pena
cuidar direitinho dele. Concorda não?
Então vamos nessa, um passo de cada vez,
um dia de cada vez, mas sempre em
frente, porque você merece viver com
saúde, com plenitude. Acredite, é
totalmente possível. Compartilhe os
vídeos, faça o bem. A vida de alguém
pode mudar também no canal do além do se
envolva. Ja.